Oh
[Musique]
déjà ces micro dumps génèrent quand
Est-ce que tous ces incidents brûlants sont là
ce qui produit évidemment du vrai
Pollution de l'air
et en effet aussi certains
sont situés à proximité de lieux publics
[Musique]
nous en profitons
une matière première pour fabriquer notre
panneaux d'isolation thermique
parce que l'essentiel est d'éliminer le
déchets textiles du Chili et éduquer les
les gens qui peuvent réduire leur consommation
de textiles inutiles et qu'ils
prendre en charge la prolongation de la durée de vie utile des
ce
mais en achetant et en continuant
voir du cochon avant chez Zara H&M était
pour voir vos anciens et les magasins qui sont
plus orienté vers l'échec
[Musique]